everybody wants to lambo these days but
the question is how do you put a literal
flying lambo
on the literal moon many would tell you
the answer is
dogecoin what what is dogecoin
dogecoin dogecoin is back what is your
thoughts on
dogecoin right now it will probably
cease to exist
in a five-year time frame dogecoin is
likely to reach the 20
mark yes dogecoin there's been a lot of
talk about it is it the biggest thing to
happen to finance since tesla
or is it just all smoke before during
and after
doge day which is april 20th or 4 20 for
the more sophisticated
among you many people have been talking
about doge
and many of you have come to me to
seafood the to the owner of the 10
million
studio with burning questions people
like my buddy graham
what is dogecoin is this sustainable all
good questions
now normally my response is just a
string of useless buzzwords i like to
confuse people
uh so the bitcoin maximalists don't
freak out and jump me and say you know
some i try to give them something that
can be interpreted
either way so i can't get in trouble i
usually say something like this
oh there is ico coming so you must make
sure blockchain
ledger d5 fintech and you know about
that cause bitcoin go to the moon wall
street
bet globally flower bees are now on sale
i did just check the alpha's dogs and
did you go discord server ruby doobie
now normally that scares people off they
they don't stick around for the rest of
it and that's what i'm happy with but
people keep asking about doge so today
unlike my normal answer i'm actually
going to give an answer what i think of
doge what is the case for dogecoin
what's the case against dogecoin we're
going to talk about it
oh should you respect the pump always
guess respect the pump
i respect the pump in all assets all
right long story short
it's probably a huge bubble now before
you guys jump me and say he's a no
coiner
that's how they get you they go you're a
no coiner or you're gonna say i'm a
hater or jealous because crypto go bur
uh let me just say this look i'm a i'm a
fan i'm an investor and a long-term
believer
in the future of crypto broadly but i
simultaneously hold that belief
and also the belief that like vast
majority 98
of crypto projects are gonna blow up in
the next five to ten years
and completely fall apart while the real
winners are gonna be
slow projects with actual utility and
usefulness and to explain why i know
many of you are already typing in the
comments angrily
that doge will be the all-time greatest
crypto ever
slow down let me explain to explain we
have to go back in time to the dawn
of the world wide web before memes were
ever a thing before rick
ever rolled anybody don't worry this is
all coming back to doge
it's called the dot-com bubble which i
know most of you
uh don't know what that is but it was a
period of intense
speculation about the internet and the
future of tech companies in the late 90s
here is basically the central thesis
of this time period the conclusion that
we came to rightly or wrongly so was
that the internet was going to
fundamentally change the way business
was run
across the board in every sector of of
business so basically because the
internet's going to change anything you
got to
get your piece you got to make sure
you're a part of it so you can get huge
gains
and companies were popping up left and
right with
you know just attaching their name to
a.com and getting millions in venture
capital people were literally just
throwing money at any project
that had a modicum of a modem and
internet access
and to just give you an example of how
crazy things were listen to what
happened to uh this mortgage company
when they attached.com
next to their name when seth werner
changed the name of his first mortgage
network
to mortgage.com and went on the net the
estimated market value jumped from 100
to 800 million dollars now in case it's
not obvious the point i'm making here is
that you can basically
replace a few words like internet with
crypto
and get a synopsis of the current state
of investing and speculation within
crypto
you could describe it like this crypto
is a game changer it's here to stay
let's grab a piece of some
of these future companies and get huge
gains this is exactly
what the people during the dot-com
bubble we're thinking it's the same
impulse
and look 20 some years later we should
be able to learn some lessons
and apply it to today because while it
isn't the exact same similar principles
apply and look here's
a clip from a dot-com documentary to
explain some of the insane culture and
just in your head
replace dot-com with crypto replace
internet with blockchain and i think a
lot will probably resonate
here with the current state of crypto
speculation
over and over again scenes like this one
would play out at the dot-coms
on the day their company's stock went
public employees would watch the value
of their stock options soar
making paper millionaires out of many of
them
between 1990 and mid-2000 more than 4
700 new companies debuted on america's
stock exchanges
everybody thought they could get rich
quick everybody across from retail
investor to investment bank we had this
period where
money was growing on trees which is
totally cool while it's going on i'm
sure it was
totally cool and i'm sure also if you
questioned at the time any of the
arbitrary like dot-com valuations
you would have also been deemed a hater
or better yet like your anti-internet
just because you don't like you think
some of these companies are overvalued
but eventually obviously what goes up
must come down
then came the crash i mean it was
absolutely horrendous
billions of dollars of value was lost
overnight wiping out a lot of
million dollar companies here's the
interesting thing the long-term
thesis that the internet is here to stay
is
true though and a few notable exceptions
from the dot-com era survived
such as amazon.com and yes if you would
have been smart you would have invested
in them for pennies on the dollar
and left the rest of them alone but how
does that help us today
i think the irrational exuberance shown
by today's market like in crypto with
dogecoin with all these uh
huge cryptos that are exploding
overnight with big clout
being a one billion dollar company in a
month look
it's driven by a true idea i believe is
true which is that
uh crypto's gonna revolutionize the
financial industry and potentially more
but
the valuations of individual cryptos are
almost completely divorced from reality
at this point
just like the valuations of individual
tech stocks were divorced from the
reality back in that day too
and just like young inexperienced tech
founders were getting millions of
dollars in venture capital
crypto teams are now doing nothing and
getting billion dollar market caps
overnight
like dogecoin for example just passed
the valuation of ford
you know like a real company with real
revenues
and a meme coin driven by pure
speculation stimulus checks and a bull
market
hey it's worth more that makes sense
right uh no
safe moon is another crypto which we
will be covering soon guys it's exploded
recently we're gonna cover it as soon as
we can
reached a billion dollar market cap also
in a month
of launching think about that this
cryptocoin nobody knows if it will be
successful pure speculation billion
dollars
it's completely insane 98
of these projects will fall apart mark
my words and look i think the smartest
thing to do if you realize all of this
and you recognize this is you just try
to learn from history
this cannot last all these cryptos you
know simultaneously succeeding and
reaching higher and higher highs
eventually there will be a crypto crash
and any influencer telling you otherwise
telling you like unironically to the
moon bro they're lying to you
everything is speculation on who will
win long term and most of these
valuations are going nowhere but
zero the truth about crypto is that a
few winter coins are going to dominate
most of the market while the rest
eventually get crumbs just like today
google facebook
amazon they just dominate the market and
you know your average blog doesn't isn't
some giant success
now am i telling you to stay away from
crypto altogether though not at all i i
think
if you look at the dot-com bubble you
could still get great companies for
pennies on the dollar who have survived
till today but
catching those winners was not about
just like blindly
listening to all the hype and whatever
it's about doing the opposite you have
to ignore the hype and pay attention to
fundamentals i can't believe i'm saying
this not pumpamentals
okay and it also means you have to be
careful and realize
you could be wrong wildly wrong about
who's gonna last and
if you're gonna go invest make sure it's
money you can afford
to lose now with all of that said what
are the so-called fundamentals of
dogecoin well let's listen to the most
bullish dogecoin fan the meme lord
himself
elon musk the point is that dogecoin was
invented as a joke as essentially to
make fun of cryptocurrency
um and that's why uh i think i think
there's like an argument like fate loves
irony
like the most entertaining outcome is
the most like probably the most ironic
outcome
that the the currency that was invented
as a joke in fact becomes the real
currency
right no absolutely to the moon to the
moon
uh yes the meme hypothesis of economics
capable of explaining things such as
game stunk it's a good idea honestly
it's a novel theory
the fact that dogecoin isn't trying to
be anything but a joke
like and that being why it's attractive
to speculators it makes some sense
when you think about why it's so viral
but and i sound like the old dad on the
line going you
kids look
dude fundamentals everyone care about
dude fundamentals are so lame now
but really we have to eventually ground
our valuations in some kind of like
actual use case i mean it's all great to
be the meme stock
until people actually start using
cryptos and then it's like okay well
what does your crypto do
that i should actually put money in it
and that's the whole problem with tech
stocks in the 90s was
nobody was looking at are these
companies actually useful and valuations
weren't based on
real revenue and they crashed because of
it and this is where i completely
disagree
uh with mr i will put a little dogecoin
on the literal moon
elon musk the most memeable outcome is
not the most likely one look i've just
given my opinion
here i know i'm not linking my mind to
uh a monkey like
elon musk is but i think if you look at
tack the most value-creating company
was the most likely outcome google
facebook none of these were meme stocks
they were companies with actual usage
actual like use case so in the same way
i think cryptocurrency
like right now when nobody's really you
know won
yes meme stocks are gonna win but when
people actually start using cryptos
the one with actual like usage in the
real world will be the winner whether
that be d5 exchanges like uniswap
or stores of value like bitcoin that's
why i'm not gonna be investing in
dogecoin and
i encourage no one else to do so either
and if you are someone who's still a fan
of dogecoin
i think that's fine if you look at it
for what it is which is
gambling right things like dogecoin safe
moon a lot of these
coins they're just like big plays that
probably will die off very soon and if
you know you're investing in something
that's going to fall apart
i guess do what you want with your money
right and i think there are some
secondary cases about dogecoin too like
that there's one person holding 30 of
the total currency
uh and i think there are some other
problems as well but the most relevant
point is this
will dogecoin be a crypto that stays
around or is it gonna be a flash crash
i think it's the latter that's why i
don't hold it and if you disagree
i'd love to hear why because whether
you're a fan of doge safe moon
bitcoin ethereum or you don't hold any
of them you can always pump
one thing for sure zillow absolutely for
free
you can pop the stock by liking and
subscribing and i appreciate all of the
support thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed this deep dive and i'll see you
guys in the next one
wake up and smell the coffee